hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights with 39 now
before you go on about me you know
playing another five nights at Freddy's
fan game the only reason I'm playing
this one is because supposedly it's
funny and I really really enjoy the
humorous takes on five minutes of Freddy
and I'm pretty sure dabbing it is that
guy a bit wait hang on I did it I dabbed
a my hip with the kids so I'm gonna play
refund apparently there's like six
nights of this ah I'm just gonna play it
until it stops being funny because I
really really liked all the funny
five nights at Freddy's fair hmm [ __ ]
you buddy
5 9 f NBF boiler blow ha ha I killed
your kid in my last game caught a bum
boot go down to fazbear's adverts to do
oh boy will I be responsible for all
injury and just remember at school I
play very simple observed 39 on the
cameras for trophies or listen for his
movement
always check the doors in Casey's there
and his movement is completely random it
would come into the office and drain
power and you'll be temporarily stunned
when he enters you must click on his
nose and make him believe ah
that's adorable except for killing that
guy's kid thing I have no idea how this
is gonna go
I've never even heard of the games from
this developer apparently he's made
money honestly did not think you would
turn up well welcome to the adverts idea
of an i YT I don't know why I'm an
electronic character I swear to God have
no idea me it's like someone pull this
idea out of their ass and crafted it
within one week you know that I think
that's basically what it is so
apparently you are paralyzed ah sucked
in so you can't move at all until 6 a.m.
brilliant then you get to watch me run
around the cameras doing my own thing
and I'll eventually pop in and visit you
so yeah yeah yep I'm a good night okay
coming thanks like looks dangerous
this looks dangerous what I can't see
anything on here everything is flash
licensed Oh nope the hell what is
happening I've no idea what's happening
tell me a reason why why am i why can't
I see the camera oh it's like just do it
I can't click on the cameras that ever I
can't see anything number one number two
I'm paralyzed
is that your father B I have no idea but
do I like it already
boop knows of a weight of course there
is he him 8 3987
whatever his name is I don't know all
right thank you
is that supposed to spook me didn't work
I'm on bookable did you know that can't
be spooked no matter how hard you try so
just try give it to me gimme I'm here
hey boogie woogie whoo piggy that a
boogie oh man I love that oh that's
hilarious
oh man I remember playing through all of
the five nights at Ricky boy games and
oh so funny I don't know why I can't see
anything in here WCE but I guess I just
gotta wait here I guess I have no idea
so I'll just skedaddle II widely until
he comes by ah God ah cool you did you
sure got a bigger pot where I drink pal
to make things very intense
ah boo boo boo
we're gonna go my mom is technique I did
this seems like I'm all alone here boo
boo anybody on here yet scam not working
I'm still not working okay don't sneak
on me but don't go on me boo
maybe he's gone away boy I guess I
should just drop my guard and relax
about all this cuz they're done to the
word oh maybe it's nothing maybe it
doesn't maybe I should just take a nap
too tired
[Music]
ha ha got you too
hello you just gonna stand there though
you do stand there and they're tight no
I got you Joey now when you're waiting
Jesus baby I know it's the first night
so there's got to be more stuff that it
comes near by but there's actually just
really pulling look what is the point
what's the point of view and checking
the light what's the point of checking
the camera when there's nothing here I
mean I know glows green but that's just
where it is and then these cameras are
disabled or something there's nothing
there anyway like econ the reason why
heisman painted on walls do you mean
what do you mean by that what does that
mean would it talking about
Oh wrong be like oh I go let ya leg you
play I am Glenn alright I'll keep going
it happened night - oh hey how's it
going you holding up your ears to be
two-finger you come back from oh I oh I
can just keep on doing this
AHA honestly gonna war but I seem to
have fun running around app it's free
every night keep tripping over letters
and cursing and everything honestly I
may be kind of [ __ ] you know like it
did you know they don't thank God that
censored everyone would have my head if
they knew what I just said alright boy
I'm in a more hyper mood tonight and I'm
down to get my heart that's around every
night so you know same deals last night
just a little bit faster Oh know what
the point of all this is again anyway
good night yeah I don't know the point
of it is because again can't see [ __ ]
nothing to see nothing's happening sleep
long oh it's already 1:00 a.m. and the
nights go so quick I love it I could
just sit here laughs good this is the
part where I train pal amazing very
intense okay alright then goodbye
have a good one it's not this can't be
all there is right there's got to be
more to this than there's this lovely
bleep okay alright then what was that
all about
alright I guess I'll just wander here in
my loneliness thinking about all my past
accomplishments of kicking animatronics
asses you know I have a crown it's
pretty cool right
I know you jealous okay okay ow
the big bubble blowing baby over there
yeah I just realize I'm I'm screaming at
a doorway yeah hey you there come on peg
why my name is Magua I'm here to tell ya
gotcha ha ha ha what's the point it
comes in anyway anyway that's the point
you messed up my monologue my mind blade
590 Freddy's 110 lot 1
he called you Fred so come at me breath
I don't find a way to stab union
remember what happened to Barney it fan
that phrase do oh hey ripped off I'm
gonna do that to you what i'ma rip your
butt all the way off and shut it down
your head you're gonna have an ass for a
face on fan art about to make it real
this is the part where I print out it
may seem very intense yeah oh no I'm
sorry I'm sorry about that did I hurt
you I apologize anyway I'm gonna tear
off your ah you know how in five nights
at Freddy's 2 yeah I had to wear
Freddy's head you're gonna have to wear
your own nice I'm very spooked about
that do you know how spooked I am very
you know I've survived a lot of
incarnations from you and I don't think
you're too threatening I was even you in
another game remember Bonnie simulator
that was like that was another one of
those like really funny five minutes of
Freddy's fan games like I love the funny
ones just because it pokes fun at it but
in a good way that kind of pays homage
to the original in it it's just a little
silly and I like this bite-sized pizza
filling this year I win yeah give me my
award I know just come on give me my
award I'm good I'm not even gonna bother
doing anything else
mmm vodka it's not I died water
how's going on I don't yeah see now I'm
demanding if I even need the pressure
knows because I think I'm gonna win just
gonna stand there look like a grumpy Gus
honk ooh beeping move head Oh too late
or didn't read oh no sorry about you
sorry about how much you suck I know you
were born with a biscuit I welcome every
word oh I hate my hey how you doing how
you doing over there
yeah it's becoming a thing now is this
like a king fahd not before friends gosh
I mean come on man don't don't
lately put up with you for another three
not actually turned out to be another
two nights because you know Scott
Cawthon really chew over that way
seriously I'm starting to get a bit
tired of you man but I'm still in a
pretty hyper mode so I'm going to be
even more active tonight oh good I mean
I'm sick of you touching my nose to
really pisses me off I feel like I'm
cute in this pose don't you reckon yeah
I feel like I'm cute in this powder
don't you reckon oh [ __ ] with that are
you talking about can actually see
something on the camera down cool kind
of pose are you cute and why did you
repeat it that supposed to be a clue oh
bloody thing did you trip over it nobody
did crippled or something oh boy I'm
sitting through all five night to this
huggy wiki well mother from her oh do
brush it on the bloody thing looks like
[ __ ] glosses no on it where no one is
there know what is in order there
one is there none is there no anything
naughty there no one is there
no one is there you are
actually happen huh okay no but all
right fine then I'm just screaming for
no reason what all right then fine
you're just making a fool out of me
cool that's really huh
yeah buddy ha ha ha do you hear another
oh your curse word got interrupted by
the bong well we got 6 a.m. with
absolutely nothing happening I took a
sip of water and they were here are you
gonna be WJ oh oh you body's ready to be
a little grumpy bunny oh yo knife is
hard draft average mobility okay fine
then
by then they did well I guess this is
going to be like that cash grab pieces
series five nights at Freddy's just a
couple more knives I mean you're really
starting to get to me man I mean jeez so
what it's so what if I killed your son I
mean that's what we exist animatronics
do because for some reason when children
are murdered and they're put into
animatronics suits they've become
murderers it makes so much sense doesn't
it oh yeah okay I literally could not
think of anything else to say I'm going
to be more active as always I really
should stop telling you that every night
because you're basically not a drill
you Sam oh I'm Sam Am I I'm Sam
apparently I'm Sam I thought I was ex
bond Rubick vishna batch daddy I think I
just got terminal cancer you were the
one dabbing on the main menu the part
where I drank powder making very intense
oh oh oh don't cry about it
a beauty Ricky would love
so are you going to be so active that I
gotta actually pay attention here
because that seems like [ __ ] to me I
don't I have to do that up Luke you
would be weird enough
well the closing Vega 10 degrees all
four four four four nine four four am
44% left that's nice I always live for
the moment I'm going to make a love for
you because then I can make a wish now I
could wish for you to go away
Olive wish one my whiskey today in my
name I love hey wait a min I was in
paying attention alright good no I I
have a feeling it's gonna get to a point
girl he's just there so much there's no
way to win there's no way to prevent him
obviously that's not a thing that
happened but uh yes if it is what it is
oh nice laughs what are you gonna say
about me sassy sue come on bring it on
I'm a lost nada put up a ghost anymore
Sam and this called for a celebration
I have written down a few insults I
would like to share with you right now
we're good I'm ready
let me go man if I be drowned in a
stagnant pool you good for nothing yep
yes that is one edge a key with the
right heel to my sense is pretty good
you can't miss connections oh you so
brutally that your kitchen will break
for months I don't know how I'll get the
end of this place and I really don't
want to give it yeah yeah I do me
incredibly I only work on that one huh
oh yes and my last one
suck a pound of putrid and that's
basically in a Gotham now okay I'm so
king excited they'll be able to take
this center of everything bother me for
the past five benign ah
Spencer will be going tomorrow I'll be
able to do what I like yay oh yay
and yes let's end this night yay let's
do it her final night maybe well yeah
like hi buddy how you doing there how's
the nose oh good oh you say you buddy
oh come on aboard we're not even there
you're not even there to spook me try to
go monitors I feel like you're not
participating in this conversation hello
no not there again look if you want to
learn look at the autopsy use the Fox
you sick okay all right you know I feel
like dialogue is broken down here you
need to actually listen to your feelings
deep inside I know deep inside is the
dead child but I think you're that rule
another disconnect with your feelings
man 39 or Bonnie or whatever you are
whatever that is or whatever you want to
be because you can be whatever you want
to be come talk to me man it's a lonely
look you Ricky mother that's not talking
to me is just talking at me I wish I
could
well that was south weird are you here
to apologize
I feel like dialogue is actually
starting now come on talk to me continue
you can make things right I mean you
can't bring my dead son back but come on
try you wants to say something oh man
just like I feel we're getting somewhere
runs away hydrogen gigantic ugly nose he
runs away oh you can do it take as many
times as you need I believe in you
alright we're done here then good boy
honor the business
Oh Rafi I'm not in touch with my
emotions
all right come on Williams now the
torture comes to an end I get to take my
sensor off and go on with my life and
you get to [ __ ] off oh and go on the
Gila no you so let's end it right here
catch you later mate
okay oh and if you come back you will be
sorry all right
oh I'm I'm gonna come back hey Debbie
McNab person.this let's have another go
come on I don't want to wait around for
this I'm back baby he's gonna make me
sorry
warning extremely offensive content you
heard
[ __ ] doing it what you want going
back that's it
dance because it oh I got a few things
to say to you might do I in an ocean of
flour you piss your ball [ __ ] I'm sure
you want to suck my anus you grungy [ __ ]
run along and gobble a breaker of [ __ ]
milk you son of a [ __ ]
you have leprosy don't worry though the
news isn't all bad you're also going to
die well over the notion of anal pus you
miserable son of a [ __ ] it will be more
than all right if you shut your [ __ ]
cry hold your senseless barrel of dicks
I've heard that incase if you're crying
I don't want you around here even your
closest friends don't want you around no
chance it would be the best for everyone
if you threw yourself up the tallest
building you could find I heard that
they wish you would die so die Sam quad
for [ __ ] hell
Sam you know what it's good [ __ ] it I'm
coming for you man you are
[ __ ] okay alright then come at me bro I
don't know if I'm gonna have enough
power by the end of this but you know
I'll try I don't think you're gonna
drain me sorry I interrupted your
private session with your body pillow
I'll let you get back to your hand hi
Adam mangas in the near future just bear
with me for a few more seconds as I try
to you know looky-looky win over you
look uh you are wrong that's what I'm
here for that's what I've been trying
this whole time man been trying right
realize I know you've been trying real
hard but listen not about bad yeah I'm
pretty sure this is set up for failure
I'm pretty sure the only way to get
through this is to lose all your power
and die because you walked in on a messy
masturbating Noorani brillo hmm no shot
for him but he delay so I think it's
gonna end and then when he kills me
there's gonna be something good at the
end oh maybe maybe be so much better but
you have to go with someone else hmm
now I don't know what that means things
could have been so much better but you
have to go with someone else me me have
to go or you she had to go with someone
else I couldn't quite understand you
lift bra I I lifted your nose off of
your super face yeah it's not good if
you're expecting the toreador March well
you got another thing coming okay I
don't think there's any way to win that
because I just don't think there's
enough power left it could be like a
random thing where you just like
randomly maybe win that but I think it's
worth it I think is funny enough I I did
honestly didn't think that I would go
through the whole game like this but I
like this a lot it was pretty funny I
would any in five nights at freddys fan
don't think it too seriously obviously
it's nice to just make fun of it every
once in a while and those guys obviously
this characters supposed to be an
[ __ ] and that's fine so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to play this for yourself and
maybe night six is beatable I don't know
I just don't have the willpower to try
to beat it because I've just been
sitting here waiting and enjoying the
show so thank you everybody so much
there'll be a link in the description
and as always
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]